nothing to say don't ever come at me
like that the trailer for the new season
of Keeping Up with the Kardashians packs
a punch this brief promo for the show's
eighteen season teases all kinds of
family drama why do you have to have an
attitude don't involve yourself in
business that is not yours then don't
talk about it in front of me as well as
some awkward encounters she can't sit
back and just be like alright I was
wrong
but the moment everyone is talking about
comes at the trailers final moments
which shows Kim and Kourtney seemingly
in a physical altercation nothing to say
don't ever come at me like that
this comes months after the rumors that
Kourtney was considering leaving the hit
reality series which last season's
finale seems to confirm it's not okay
that I feel like I'm at my breaking
point and I need a break and I don't
want to film anymore life is short if
you not have all about filming this show
yeah about enjoying that's why we're
doing this so then we have time to enjoy
I don't have time to enjoy I'll do
something else we haven't really done
anything together the three of us and so
long and it really has at least for a
decade really been the three of us
easy spoke with the sisters the last
fall you mentioned that you might be
ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up with
the Kardashians where are you at on that
um I'm just decided to spend more time
as a mom and you know put more of my
energy there and still but I'm not
saying goodbye right but I think you'll
have to see more of it on the new season
season 18 just crazy isn't airing yet
but it's being filmed okay and currently
do you want in this room do you think
the show can continue going if you lose
a sister yeah I mean we definitely love
portney and we will miss core
and whatever she decides to do but
people come people go all the time this
family we feel like it's a revolving
door
so Courtney might leave this week she'll
be back they all come back
it's he also acts the executive producer
Ryan Seacrest about Courtney's future
with the series Kourtney Kardashian said
she would be happy if the cameras went
away she was how do you feel about that
and how many more seasons of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians won't first few
going if the cameras go away as long as
they can come back Courtney you know
they can go away for a little bit but
bring them back so we can do another
season or two Alyssa I don't know how
honestly I don't know how they do it
they've lived for over a decade with
cameras following I could not do it no
matter what they were paying them I
couldn't do it so I give them a lot of
credit from those cameras in their lives
all the time and I love you coordinator
[Music]